so I thought the ending was fantastic
and
um just the the scene with you and
Amanda and being able to talk
um talk a little bit about how you guys
decided where the show should end and
your thoughts on the ending of the show
I mean it was a really long conversation
that span over almost the entirety of
the shoot there were multiple different
endings to the show and ultimately we
wanted the show to end on a conclusive
resolve we wanted the audiences to feel
fulfilled
um and I feel like we did that we
obviously have the little kind of
Twinkle in the eye at the end of like is
there more to this story and seeing Adam
in in the uh in the window at the end
um but I'm incredibly proud of the
ending my final scene on the stand is a
scene that I don't think I will ever be
in my career I'm so proud of what we
achieved there I remember reading that
scene for the first time and just
thinking this isn't gonna work it's too
difficult and and I feel like we pulled
it off so I feel very very honored and
very proud do you think that uh Danny
and his mom can never have a
relationship or you think that no chance
I always live by the idea of Never Say
Never
because who knows
um
but at the end of the show it seems like
they probably will go their separate
ways but I'd like to think that they
would be able to find a way to uh to
rekindle their relationship I thought
the opening credits were very cool but
they have such a better meaning at the
end of episode 10. Yeah you sort of talk
about how you guys uh like talk about
how like the how you decided on the
opening credits and it's tied to the end
it's a really interesting question you
know like with all the films I've done
and films where I've been a producer on
I've never been involved in that aspect
of of the show the opening credits and
the end credits has never been something
that's ever come across my desk you know
per se for sitting down and figuring out
what we're gonna do because the opening
credits to a TV show is important you
know that song that it plays the visuals
it really gets people going and I think
it was akiva's idea to kind of tell the
story through the watercolor paintings
um and I think it was a great idea
because I just think that the song is
excellent there are little Snippets in
there of clues of things to come and uh
and I look forward to getting my hands
on some of the original art to uh to put
in my house it's so funny um caramel Del
Toro when he does a film he makes two of
everything to make sure that he takes
home everything right he's a super
collector so I was gonna I was gonna ask
you
um are you getting any of the paintings
are you working that into your contract
in the future that like cool things from
what you're making get to come home with
you I don't think you necessarily have
to have those things in your contract
you know
um Sony you know they've already said
that I can keep my Spidey suits they
they stole them for me and and I'm very
grateful for them I'm sure you know
someone at Apple will allow me to have a
copy of some of the artwork
um to put in my house because I am
incredibly incredibly proud of the show
um so I don't necessarily think I'll be
putting that in my contract but I do
have quite an extensive collection of
things I've done over the past one of
the things that was really cool also is
the way you uh depict Danny's mind and
having the characters in like the barn
you know coming through and who takes
the lead can you sort of talk about
filming those sequences and how you guys
decided that that's what how you wanted
to depict the inside of Danny's mind
well this is what I love about our job
is that the person that came up with the
idea of the barn was actually my brother
we were on set we were you know figuring
out what we were going to do for the
crowded room at one point it was going
to just be this kind of endless expanse
of Darkness with water everywhere and we
just felt like we'd seen that before and
we couldn't figure it out and my brother
piped up and said the birthplace of the
crowded room is the barn wouldn't it be
really cool if in episode 7 he goes back
to the barn and has to face the music
which is obviously you know a phrase
from one of the episodes and I love that
our producing Department were so
collaborative that my little brother
who's on set with me had the freedom to
you know pipe up in a meeting and say I
think it should be in the barn yeah it
all it totally works um I also like I
said I like the way it depicts the
different characters who's in the front
you know um I already gotta go I'm just
gonna say sincerely congrats and uh nice
talking with you always nice talking
with you mate I'll see you next time